[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
quentin calme mais nous sommes heureux
de recevoir marie pierre de la gontrie
bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice
socialiste de paris et c'est quentin qui
dresse votre portrait bonjour brigitte
bonjour un père de la gontrie alors vous
êtes avocate de profession vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur les sujets liés à
la justice au sens du parti socialiste
pendant quinze ans vous avez été l'une
des vice présidentes de jean paul huchon
à la région ile-de-france et en 2017
vous rejoignez le sénat et sa
prestigieuse commission des lois vous
est également très proche d'anne hidalgo
la maire de paris candidate à l'élection
présidentielle alors tout d'abord une
question d'actualité le pass sanitaire
prolongée dans un texte qui sera débattu
en conseil des ministres le 13 octobre
guérir et a annoncé mercredi vouloir
proposer de maintenir la possibilité
d'avoir recours à ce passe sanitaire
jusqu'à l'été on a vu une levée de
boucliers déjà au sénat est ce que c'est
à dire que le sénat va voter contre nous
le verrons mais c'est vrai que ça n'a
pas de sens parce que à gauche je suis
au groupe socialiste nous avions proposé
la vaccination obligatoire nous en
débattrons d'ailleurs le 13 octobre
puisque nous avons déposé une
proposition de loi nous savions que le
pass sanitaire pouvait être utile pour
inciter à la vaccination d'ailleurs ça a
marché puisque aujourd'hui 85% 85 % des
français sont totalement vacciner donc
aujourd'hui on sait que on le voit aux
chiffres ça n'est plus une incitation à
la vaccination c'est des cons à cette
espèce de deux plafonds de personnes qui
pour diverses raisons ne se font pas
vacciner et on constate que ça n'est pas
un facteur qui permet de ne pas faire
circuler le virus pourquoi parce qu'il
est imposé dans certains lieux et pas
dans d'autres donc par exemple il n'est
pas et heureusement il n'est pas imposé
dans le métro il n'est pas imposé dans
toute une série de circonstances en
revanche il est un
comment diable un facteur de brimades
des gens et puis surtout
le prolonger jusqu au moins jusqu'à
l'été où jusque jusqu'en fin juin c'est
extrêmement loin donc on voit bien que
le président la république veut pouvoir
enjamber l'élection présidentielle donc
nous nous y opposerons et j'ai
l'impression que nous serons tous au
sénat opposés parce que nous avons
atteint ces 85 % de vaccination nous
présenterons deux textes sur la
vaccination obligatoire le 13 octobre en
espérant qu'il soit voté et si le
président de la république voulait
absolument un passé ni terre dans ce cas
là qu'il propose de le faire pour trois
mois par exemple et qu'il fixe à nous
vous rendez vous en fais juste pour bien
comprendre ça veut dire que vous vous
êtes prête à lever le pass and it erp
vous dites on peut arrêter le passé ni
terre le 15 novembre ne prolonge pas la
loi absolument c'est à dire quand je je
je je vais essayer de dire plus de
manière plus convaincante ce que j'ai
indiqué le pass sanitaires avaient
vocation à soyons clairs faire le tri
entre les personnes vaccinées les autres
il ya une au milieu encore de personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés sur vous ça
n'aura aucun effet on m'avait dit que
l'immunité collective pouvait être un
verre 90% aujourd'hui nous sommes en 85
et 88 % ont déjà eu une première dose et
ça stagne c'est la réalité donc
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est temps un
de passer au concept de vaccination
obligatoire vous savez la nouvelle
calédonie par exemple qui a le pouvoir
de le faire imposer la vaccination
obligatoire et immédiatement les
vaccinations ont crû de manière très
importante donc il faut tenir bon sur
poussé à la vaccination et je regrette
que certains parfois donc j'étais proche
politiquement tiennent des propos un
petit peu étrange sur la question avec
ce nom qui sonne bien pour nous
christiane taubira pour qui j'ai à la
fois beaucoup d'admiration et
d'affection mais qui a tenu des propos
qui n'a pas encouragé à la vaccination
en guyane dont on va dire ça comme ça
donc le pass sanitaire n'est plus
nécessaire on fait jusqu'au 15 mai je
rappelle en plus que les tests pcr payer
des gens qui veulent pas être vaccinés
qui disent ah bah c'est pas grave je
ferai un test les deux jours il sera il
ne sera plus pris en charge sera plus
gratuit donc il va y avoir de nouveau
une petite hausse et nous pourrons
retrouver une activité normale comme
nous le disions à l'époque des guignols
de l'info mon allez on poursuit à
présent avec les titres de 7 ici on est
le sénat qui a adopté cette semaine le
projet de loi pour la confiance dans la
justice un texte qui manque d'envergure
pour les républicains qui en ont profité
pour fustiger le bilan du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron en matière de justice le
débat sur la fin de vie relancer la
chanteuse et comédienne line renaud
marraine de l'association pour le droit
à mourir dans la dignité est venu à
l'assemblée nationale soutenir la
proposition du député olivier falorni
alors si le texte a peu de chances
d'aboutir les parlementaires ont bon
espoir d'en faire une promesse
présidentielle pour 2022 jeudi le sénat
a débattu de la lutte contre la
maltraitance animale la chambre haute a
en grande partie réécrit le texte de la
majorité tout en renforçant les
sanctions pénales pour les auteurs de
maltraitance animale mais donc pour
commencer cette semaine eric dupond
moretti est venu défendre son texte sur
la confiance en la justice au sénat
alors pour l'occasion la chambre haute
avait fait réaliser un sondage
53% des français disent ne pas avoir
confiance dans cette institution est
selon eux ce n'est pas ce texte selon
les alertes ce n'est pas ce texte qui va
changer la donne résumé des débats au
sénat avec sandra sahara le garde des
sceaux a tenté de défendre son projet de
loi pour la confiance dans la justice
face à des sénateurs peu convaincue qui
ont adopté une version modifiée du texte
le constat qui m'amène ici
est simple et je ne doute pas que vous
le partagerai notre justice fait l'objet
d'une défiance grandissante
dont les causes sont en réalité multiple
le projet de loi je vous présente
aujourd'hui vise précisément à inverser
cette tendance
cette la justice à bord d'une large
variété de sujets de la procédure pénale
à l'enregistrement des procès en passant
par le travail des détenus ou la
protection des avocats et c'est
justement ce que les sénateurs lui
reproche c'est un texte fourre-tout
selon eux et qui ne va pas dans le sens
de la simplification
d'autant que c'est la sixième réforme de
la justice depuis le début du
quinquennat des dispositions
hétéroclite qui est de porter inégale
ouais
cela ne justifie en rien le caractère
quelque peu présomptueux de l'intention
affichée par ce texte j'ai été un peu
surpris du décalage entre le titre donc
j'ai annoncée de ce texte et son contenu
réel les sénateurs ont voté pour une
expérimentation jusqu'en mai 2023 et non
une mise en place immédiate des cours
criminelles départementale composée de
cinq magistrats professionnels que le
gouvernement souhaite pour les crimes
punis jusqu'à 20 ans de prison pour
remplacer des assises avec jury
populaire les sénateurs ont également
voté pour la suppression du secret
professionnel des avocats en matière de
conseil dans le cadre des enquêtes pour
la répression des délits de fraude
fiscale et de corruption il s'agit ainsi
pour eux de préserver l'efficacité des
enquêtes et de répondre aux inquiétudes
des magistrats l'activité de conseil est
une activité concurrentielle pour les
avocats on est bien d'accord la gauche
de son côté a tenté en vain de revenir
sur la fin du rappel à la loi remplacé
par un avertissement pénale probatoire
jugé plus adaptée par le gouvernement
pour répondre aux petites fautes alors
martins da contre il ya des sénateurs
qui ont parlé d'une loi fourre-tout
notamment parce que en ce moment et bien
et va y avoir des travaux sur la
procédure pénale c'est une annonce qui
avait été fait avec la fin du beauvau de
la sécurité dans ce contexte qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette loi sur la
confiance en la justice
si vous voulez moi je m'interrogeais
parce qu'on est pratiquement à la fin du
quinquennat donc la mission de dupond
moretti s'achève et au fond qu'est ce
qu'il restera de son passage qui était
une initiative assez audacieuse et pour
le président la république et est pour
lui et au fond ce texte confiance dans
la justice les gens n'ont pas confiance
pourquoi parce que c'est trop long c'est
trop cher on n'y comprend rien et
parfois ça rendait d'ailleurs justement
ce texte répond en partie à certaines
n'est pas du tout pour la réduire
dépendant d'elle dans la vraie vie dans
la vraie vie ce n'est pas la procédure
pénale ce texte ne parle que pénales
dupond-moretti sont intéressés par le
pénal on le comprend mais c'est pas ça
qui intéresse les gens je vous moi enfin
je l'espère pour vous voudrez sans doute
jamais un tribunal pénal en revanche
vous êtes intéressés par les tribunaux
civils c'est-à-dire les questions de
divorce
d'expulsion locative de consommation
tout est simple et très sociaux le
conseil des plus gros bides et a déposé
ses valises durée pour la paix dans la
justice c'est que vous puissiez vous
dire j'ai un problème je sais où je peux
m'adresser premièrement je comprends
deuxièmement ça me coûte pas une fortune
et troisièmement ça va être assez rapide
écoutez il y a eu un interview assez
décapant du nouveau procureur de nantes
progrès quand même nommé parmi eux
justice ce nouveau procureur il ya
quelques jours lors de son installation
a fait un tir nourri contre l'épaule et
la politique gouvernementale en disant
on nous demande de faire des choses que
nous n'avons pas les moyens de faire
parce qu'il faut du personnel et donc il
se passe des mois voire des années avant
qu'une décision soit rendue alors je
reviens au texte le texte il il répond à
quelques marotte du garde des sceaux
donc aura été traitée la question de la
protection du secret professionnel des
avocats vous rappeler qu'il avait été
accrochée dans une affaire excluant le
conseil non mais les affaire de fadettes
donc il ya toute une série de
dispositions qui n'intéresse pas grand
monde mais qui prévoit que c'est plus
compliqué c'est ensuite il encadre la
durée des enquêtes préliminaires c'est
des enquêtes il faut que les gens
comprennent où la personne qui fait
l'objet de l'enquète ne le sait pas
n'a pas accès au dossier donc c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué ces enquêtes de
police mans il dira mais c'est trop long
c'est pas normal donc ils les encadrons
comprend pas très bien quelle est
l'utilité bon donc au final et pour
le fils de la justice et que deux ou
trois ans on referme l'enquète parce que
quand vous faites une enquête longue si
elle est longue c'est pas parce que les
policiers se tourner les pouces c'est
pas parce que les magistrats ont envie
qu'elle dure c'est parce qu'à passer de
postes de policiers pour le faire ou
parce que les enquêtes sont très
complexes et qu'il y a des saisines
internationale et c'est donc au final
qu'est ce qu'il reste il ya quand même
des choses très concrètes dans ce texte
la loi notamment qui les sépare
est-ce que ça va permettre de renforcer
l'autorité de l'état c'est une mesure
très bon exemple un jour dupond-moretti
dit mais le rappel à la loi les gens
toute façon pense que c'est un truc pour
les 270 mille par an 20 % de la réponse
pénale se fait pas d'un rappel à la loi
c'est quoi le rappel à la loi c'est vous
avez par exemple tagué le mur de votre
immeuble être compliqué vous êtes
convoqué quelqu'un vous fait ce qui
s'appelle un rappel à la loi c'est une
première forme
c'est une forme d'admonestation bien du
coup on m'avait dit il ya quelque temps
non mais tout ça c'est pas suffisant on
va supprimer et puis s'est rendu compte
que les magistrats disent eux-mêmes mais
oui mais c'est quoi du coup là la
première réponse alors il nous a inventé
un truc qui te sais c'est le rappel à la
loi au canada dry c'est à dire que ça
s'appelle de mai - l'avertissement
pénale probatoire donc c'est la même
chose sauf que ça s'appelle pas pareil
sauf qu'il ya eu double sanction si je
suis la terre ici et qui suit le délit
c'est paraît il sera sanctionné deux
fois ça ne peut pas permettre d'éviter
la récidive de lutter contre la primo
délinquance par exemple c'est la même
chose c'est à dire que le rappel à la
loi aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
comment dire qu'il ne sût ce qui ne
suspend pas l'action publique cinq
milieux qui n'empêche pas le parquet de
vous poursuivre plus tard
donc je n'ai pas de vue la garantie de
sanctions s'il ya un nouveau délit dans
l'année qui suit la même manière
pourquoi voulez-vous que lorsqu'un
nouveau délice se produise le parquet ne
poursuivent pas donc
deux exactement nous aurons dans
quelques jours le texte sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale qui était la
réponse à la faire ça halimi parce que
le président la république avait dit ah
mais ça ne va pas il faut modifier ça
vous verrez on peut prendre rendez vous
il va finalement proposer quelque chose
qui fait que les choses ne vont pas
vraiment changé parce qu'en réalité les
textes convenait globalement si les
cours criminelles qui doivent remplacer
en grande partie les cours d'assises
pour les crimes punis jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison est ce que vous vous êtes
d'accord avec la droite sénatoriale qui
préfèrent poursuivre l'expérimentation
jusqu'en 2025 alors je mets de côté
l'aspect symbolique dupond-moretti
d'ailleurs s'était engagé avec la main
sur le coeur il ya longtemps quand il
était avocat en disant les cours
d'assises
c'est le fondement même de la justice
effectivement il a changé il a changé à
ce point après tout les gens ont le
droit de changer d'avis mais bon et ça a
été proposé quelques temps pourquoi
parce que tout simplement c'est trop
lourd à organiser selon les injustices
de l'époque c'était nicole belloubet
parce qu'il faut des jurés étaient bien
donc a été décidé d'instaurer ces
chambres c'est court crime de criminels
c'est ça la relève est assurée voilà qu
il ya plus de jurés populaires c'était
vraiment des expérimentations bas sauf
qu'on l'a pas fait l'expérimentation ça
a duré un an ça devait durer trois ans
pas inintéressant d'expérimenter gers à
conclusif pour vous ah mais c'est pas ça
c'est qu'on n'en sais rien parce que ça
n'a duré qu'un an et donc on n'est pas
allé jusqu'au bout et donc donc ce que
j'ai une impression fisam ans de recul
dont vous vous dites on poursuit
l'expérimentation c'est ce qu'on a
demandé et la droite du sénat également
donc c'est la mort des cours d'assises
selon vous à terme clamant clairement
alors après on peut avoir un débat de
fond très intéressant sur le fait de
savoir si pierre mascitti c'est
absolument voilà conserver les cours
d'assises pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
aussi attaché était à 10 da mais ça
prendrait bien plus longtemps que votre
émission de ce matin mais non mais c'est
un débat intéressant parce qu'au fond
est-ce qu'on a raison de s'accrocher à
ce symbole qu'est ce qu'il signifie
rappelez-vous nicolas sarkozy avait
voulu introduire des jurys populaires
dans les tribunaux correctionnels en
disant bah finalement bon finalement ça
n'avait pas marché donc tout ça se pense
ça se pense mais quand on fait une
expérimentation d'un an et puis on se
précipite voilà on va passer un tout
autre sujet à présent et on va parler de
la fin de vie avec une visite remarquée
cette semaine à l'assemblée celle de la
chanteuse et comédienne line renaud elle
est venue défendre la proposition de loi
du député olivier falorni en tant que
marraine de l'association du droit à
mourir dans la dignité elle a imploré le
gouvernement de voter ce texte le plus
vite possible elsa
line renaud aux invités remarquer au
palais bourbon la star de 93 ans est
venue pour défendre une cause qui lui
est très chère ayant vécu libre et digne
je ne peux pas imaginer mourir enchaîné
quand pinte si notre vie nous appartient
ils doivent absolument en être de même
pour notre mort autour d'elle un
représentant de chaque groupes
politiques de l'assemblée nationale un
rendez vous porté par le député olivier
falorni il veut remettre le dossier de
la fin de vie à l'agenda politique et
médiatique
nous arrivons dans une période
évidemment de campagne présidentielle
donc c'est la volonté que ce sujet cette
grande réforme progressiste soit au
coeur du débat public ce que suggère le
député c'est de reprendre sa proposition
de loi en avril dernier elle n'avait pas
pu être examinées en entier en raison
des milliers d'amendements déposés par
quelques parlementaires les républicains
mais les députés avaient tout de même
adopté à une très large majorité
l'article 1 du texte qui permette une
aide active à mourir pour toute personne
souffrant d'une infection grave dont les
douleurs ne peuvent être apaisées
le gouvernement avait alors souhaité
temporiser et prône une meilleure
application de la loi classe léonetti
sur les directives anticipées
marie pierre de la gontrie vous avez
vous même rédigé un texte une
proposition là pour établir un droit à
mourir dans la dignité vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui on ne meurt pas dignement
en france j'avais repris ce cet intitulé
parce que c'est le nom de l'association
qui a porté depuis plus de 40 ans ce
sujet et dont line renaud et marraines
l'association pour droit de mourir dans
la dignité et j'avais donc porté leurs
propositions ce texte est venu
d'ailleurs au mois de mars au sénat et
n'a pas été adopté mais d'une très
courte majorité ce qui est intéressant
ça veut dire que le sénat évoluent aussi
sur sur ces questions à l'index
d'olivier falorni a été lui mais ces
gars-là mickeline dénoter absolument
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que
effectivement on ne peut pas lorsque on
est en fin de vie si on n'est pas
vraiment en train de mourir comment dire
avec un pronostic à quelques jours ou
quelques heures on ne peut pas
bénéficier de moyens pour finir sa vie
dans des conditions décentes vous savez
celle qui l'a le mieux illustré est là
elle a souhaité que ça soit racontée
c'est pour ça que je me permets de
l'évoquer c'est notre collègue
parlementaire peut l'être guinchard
qu'un seul air lines et et secrétaires
d'état aux personnes âgées à l'époque
elle n'était pas favorable à ce qui est
ce dispositif possible pour la pour la
fin de vie et puis elle a été très
malade et lorsqu'elle a considéré qu'
elle était dans une situation physique
qui ne lui permettait plus de vivre dans
des conditions correctes elle a souhaité
elle a souhaité s'est adressé à
l'hôpital de sa ville et on lui a dit
mais non entre guillemets vous n'allez
pas suffisamment mal donc vous voulez
quoi
le sénat l'a vu mourir on sait
exactement c'est donc un suicide et
souvent il est rasé ou un suicide
assisté pourquoi il faut savoir que
certains disent ah mais les soins
palliatifs les soins palliatifs faut
bien comprendre c'est vraiment vous êtes
un toute fin de j et on vous aide à
moins souffrir alors mais justement est
ce qu'avoir des départements français
exactement n'ont aucune unité de soins
palliatifs sélectionné pas la réponse
excusez moi j'anticipe peut-être votre
interrogation ce n'est pas la réponse
c'est à dire que on a tous vu les
affaires vincent lambert et d'autre on a
vu certains qui était on le voyait bien
dans des situations terribles mais mais
l'organisme tenait le coup et donc il ne
pouvait pas mettre un terme à cette
situation terrible compenser voulait
aller plus loin que la loi claisse
monétique qui existe en ce moment et
alors que vous le dites aussi dans le
même temps elle est même pas appliquée
dans 26 départements en france de voir
une voix aussi trois départements et qui
ont moins de 20 lits d'unité pour cent
mille habitants on voit que la loi n'est
déjà pas appliquée pourquoi ne pas aller
au bout de cette loi avant de un nouveau
droit la loi que l'ess leonetti elle
était sensé effectivement imposé le
développement de soins palliatifs il
faut savoir quand même que le plan de
développement de soins palliatifs s'est
arrêtée en 2019 et tout à coup olivier
ferrand il ya quelques jours à dire mais
finalement on va faire un nouveau plan
bien mais la loi de la society ce n'est
pas que ça du tout c'est là droit à la
sédation profonde et continue mais c'est
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure il faut
déjà être à la fin de sa vie et donc
c'est autre chose que à un moment où
vous êtes un parce que c'est quand même
pas
on a des critères quand même qu'ils sont
très précis c'est à dire qu'il faut être
atteint d'une maladie incurable qui
causent des souffrances inapaisables
insupportable et il faut tout un
encadrement médical donc ce n'est pas du
tout tient je voudrais me suicider je
sais pas comment faire il s'annonce bien
moins que les gens ces directives
anticipées vous l'avez fait alors c'est
autre chose et 18 % seulement des
français c'est d'acharnement c'est autre
chose c'est à dire qu'il faut
effectivement et c'est ce qu'on
prévoyait dans notre texte un mécanisme
soit deux tiers de confiance c'est à
dire que regarder rappelez-vous le
feuilleton c'est horrible à dire comme
ça vincent lambert on ne savait plus qui
l'éprouvé parents et d'amis ici nous
avons proposé après tout des battus
comment les choses vont se faire c'est à
dire qui peut décider tout sauf
évidemment si vous êtes vous même
suffisamment conscients pour exprimer
votre propre volonté ça va de soi les
directives anticipées c'est autre chose
c'est effectivement quelque chose ou
hulu 3 qui a l'air enfin je me
permettrai pas d'être discrète mais en
bonne santé peut moi je les fais
effectivement parce que je peux avoir un
accident demain partie des 18 % c'est
réel et français c'est vrai que c'est
une démarche qui n'est pas suffisamment
développer mais qui met de la même
manière si je peux me permettre sur la
question des dons d'organes à une époque
mais la loi a changé donc les choses se
sont améliorées rapidement vous l'avez
évoqué olivier ferrand a annoncé un
nouveau plan jusqu'en 2024 avec des
moyens ont été sacrés fous qu'il a dit
que le débat était légitime vous dites
que hay quoi il ya une trop grande
frilosité très mal à l'aise s'ils
voulaient lorsque moi j'ai regardé il ya
eu à l'époque où certains d'entre eux
d'ailleurs été de gauche voire en marche
parce qu'il faut savoir j'ai compté un
jour il ya 350 parlementaires qui ont
signé une proposition de loi c n'a plus
débuté pour que en avance sur ces
questions de genres confondus deux
chambres confondues et certains sont
membres du gouvernement voilà donc
olivier ferrand était venu lorsque le
texte est venu au sénat très mal à
l'aise parce qu'en réalité moi je n'ai
jamais compris ce qui se passait dans la
tête de d'emmanuel macron c'est un sujet
il faut le savoir 90 % des français sont
favorables et même plus de 70% de
mémoire des majoliques faut qu'on trouve
assez d'éléments pour acquis sans nom
mais dire que encore une fois vous savez
personne n'a envie je sais tout ça est
remis comment dire dans la de l'esprit
des gens au gré de l'actualité et chacun
se projette et vous comme moi en tout
cas moi ça a été mon cas lorsque
forcément lorsque j'ai vu ce qui s'est
passé pour vincent lambert ou d'autres
je me suis interrogé juste pour conclure
vous vous souhaitez que sa figure ou
est-ce que ça figurera dans le programme
d'anne hidalgo elle a déjà annoncé le
jour où elle a annoncé sa candidature à
rouen le 12 octobre elle l'a in the rain
2022 mais c'est un de ces combats depuis
longtemps avec jean luc romero qui est
l'un de ses adjoints à paris et qui
préside l'association pendant de moyens
dans la dignité allez on passe au plus
de la semaine à présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat a adopté jeudi en modifiant un
texte sur la maltraitance animale alors
il est venu de députés lrm ce texte qui
comportait deux mesures phares on peut
le dire l'interdiction des animaux
sauvages dans les cirques et dans les
delphinariums et l'interdiction des
ventes d'animaux dans les animaleries et
bien ces deux mesures sur lesquelles les
sénateurs et bien son revenu écoutez
sophie primas la présidente l ère de la
commission des affaires économiques au
sénat cette proposition de loi
cristallise bien des passions le voit
sur les réseaux sociaux c'était lent à
ses côtés positifs et cela ne m'étonne
guère la cause animale est affaire
d'émotion également de ce lien
particulier tissé par chacun de nous
avec les animaux de l'intimé conviction
que le sort de l'homme et du règne
animal sont intimement liés c'est en
réalité un sujet d'humanité mais le
règne animal est d'une grande complexité
il nécessite réflexion
compétences humilité et bien mieux que
des tweets avec une photo de petits
chatons et une approche binaire bien mal
de cette complexité alors on l'a dit ses
sénateurs un majorité de droite du
centre sont largement revenus sur les
mesures phares qui avait dans ce texte
de marcheurs comment comprendre cette
frilosité la majorité sénatoriale c'est
moi je suis une incurable optimist et
donc je pense que quand même c'est un
sujet qui avance dans l'esprit de tous
et y compris des élus c'est à dire le
fait que
un animal n'est pas un jouet n'est pas
un cadeau ne doit pas être un achat
impulsif a été que il faut en prendre
soin
de ce point de vue là moi j'ai assisté à
une partie du débat hier je trouve que
les choses ont quand même progressé
alors effectivement n'a pas été abordée
parce que ce n'était pas possible des
sujets qui divisent l'interdiction de la
chasse à courre j'ai signé la
proposition de loi de laurence rossignol
sur ce sujet effectivement les oreilles
avec ça aille plus loin sur la chasse à
courre insu la corrida par exemple la
corrida c'est un sujet qui est compliqué
qu'ils partageaient compris au sein de
notre groupe mais
écoutez les choses à l'agenda l'élevage
intensif donc en tout cas le sénat est
revenu sur la question des animaleries
en disant non mais quand même finalement
c'est surveillé parce que si c'était pas
possible ça se ferait de manière plus
sauvagement soyons positif les choses
avancent c'est d'ailleurs une
proposition de loi ce n'est pas un
projet de loi gouvernemental
c'est intéressant parce que souvent
voilà sur les sujets un petit peu
délicat c'est comme sur la fin de vie
comme sur les thérapies de conversion
avec les français sont assez sensibles à
cette question la maltraitance animale
plus aujourd'hui de bien réfléchir vous
y voyez un texte électoraliste à
quelques mois de la présidentielle non
parce que byers est assez trans partisan
non je pense qu'il ya une poussée au
sein des élus y compris marcheurs de la
prise de conscience de ces sujets et
comme le gouvernement ne fait rien et
bien juste pour ça que je fais le
parallèle avec la fin de vie où les
thérapies de conversion pour lesquelles
j'ai déposé une proposition de loi mais
une proposition de loi en marche va
venir en discussion dans quelques jours
s'il ya des sujets sur lequel le
président la république est frileux pour
des raisons que j'ignore que je ne
comprends pas intellectuellement et sur
lequel l'ailé parlementaire essayer
d'avancer sur lequel on peut se
rejoindre s'ennuie l'abandon d'animaux
par an ce texte permet effectivement
d'éviter les achats compulsifs impulsif
cd bonne chose dans l'oeil a su bien sûr
parce que mais ça passe par la sanction
ça vous plaît ça écoutez on a tous connu
ça on a été enfant on a des enfants et
on compte on sait très bien comment
est-ce que tout d'un coup on craque pas
ce qu'on voit un petit chaton dont on
n'a pas réalisé qu'il allait devenir
grand qu'il allait peut-être abîmer les
canapés qu'après il allait vivre un
certain nombre d'années et cetera moi je
me souviens très bien enfants j'ai
grandi avec des avec des chiens
j'adorais ça mais il faut pas se
raconter d'histoires au final au début
on dise à nos parents rue on va s'en
occuper et puis finalement quelques mois
ou quelques années après c'est les
parents qui sont et qui met donc c'est
vrai alors donc moi je crois oui il faut
il faut dire les choses de manière très
précise ça ne peut pas être un achat
impulsif c'est un achat de
responsabilités ça dure des années donc
ça veut dire s'occuper de l'animal y
compris quand il est malade et j'ai pas
forcément comme vous le souhaitez et
puis vous déménagez et c'est donc bien
sûr il faut que les gens entendent ça
merci marie pierre de la gontrie d'avoir
été notre invité dans parlement hebdo
merci quand un merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve bien
évidemment la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement et au tchad
[Musique]